hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing now
we just got off the train which means
that we got more of this place to
explore before we have to head off over
there there's a ton of this area here
that I haven't seen and I don't think
that the train ride is gonna be the last
of it but I want to make sure that I get
all the skills that I need to get before
I need to do that so the first thing I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna go to hellström
ranch I'm gonna fart because number one
I haven't leveled up myself in a while
hey that's nice I got more blood
building tonic and Arthur orthopedic
boots
hey dr. Scholl's made boots out here in
the wild alright it's made by the same
person that was that jogger over there
but either way this is a good place to
farm up some cows so that's exactly what
i'ma do so I'm gonna be right back
before I farm up these bad boys alright
so I got a lot of XP I got 2,800 now I'm
gonna up my Hornswoggle in the maximum
level I'm gonna up my dick to the draw I
don't know did I oh oh I just said I
needed to upgrade my normal skills I I'm
an idiot
let me get lockpick in just in case and
then I need more all of this basically
everything of this more shooting and II
definitely moxie okay that's enough of
that okay so that's good so we're gonna
go uh elsewhere now we got a whole bunch
of other stuff I need to ask Gary's what
I need to do because Gary knows Gary
knows stuff about what you're supposed
to be doing go to first go for the Oh
any other ideas
dude middle of investigating and
Michigan Oh about another saltpeter back
to the chef and oh oh oh for another
house in the desert oh I forgot about
that I had luck oh okay I got to go back
to dirt water and I gotta take care of
the house in the desert gang I forgot
about them oh let's go over to the
desert island finish that off because
it's holy [ __ ] that was so long ago that
wasn't really this long ago because I
accidentally flubber knocked up but the
reason I'm able to do this again is
remember I got to the gun slinger so I'm
not I'm not a whip whopper anymore I'm
not a cow punch he wants you I'm a I'm a
gun slinger wingy and I just got to put
door lock him in there we go arrest him
okay fellas the jig is up a muffled
voice says the law get them boys and
then partition we're locked in you hear
course have defeated sighs ah
Hornswoggle in hand over your weapons
I'll tell you what toss out your weapons
and I won't arrest you you hear quiet
but heated discussion inside eventually
a voice says all right and some pistols
fall out the window just kid just
kidding I'm still gonna rescue oh those
guns would have been amazing as a
gunslinger I could have been throwing
guns at my enemies just kidding I'm
still gonna arrest you Oh Jay Oh
dagnabbit that's house in the desert
gang all right except for the house that
is did it get away what was I supposed
to yeah I just messing with you here's
your reward
all right thank you I think I got
everybody and they're all alive well I
mean except for the dead ones but you
know that's fine oh that's so dies I
took care of all oh hey good to see you
you know you've really cleaned up the
area I'm plumb out of bounties for you
does that mean I get to be Sheriff no
but I guess I'll be marshal okay
marshals now my new middle name I think
I think that's how that works
you know I gotta go back to the saloon
man it's been forever god I saw spittoon
and my heart just left up into the
heavens I thought for a moment that yes
this is this wonderful moment I'll be
able to have this okay got the saltpeter
okay here you go
okay next thing I need is a certain kind
of hot pepper it's called a murder
pepper because it's really spicy because
it literally has a knife and kills
people who ask dumb questions the girl
in the area outside of town you should
be able to find one if you just wander
around for a while okay why am I doing
this for you I don't know but I'll
wander I guess all right doodlee do ho
ah this must be the south east western
murder pepper that feller the jewel was
looking for okay
all right in the narrow region to the
west south east western okay all right
then well II deli let's go back you
wacky I suppose II was II into the
kitchen you which any I go all right I
got your murder pepper what do you want
nice big one that'll last a while okay
if you're still looking for stuff to do
I need someone to go check my mail I
ordered a new saute knife but I haven't
gotten time to fetch it myself is the
key to my post office box okay thank you
why am i fetching your mail for you I've
got better things to do there's a whole
train in fresco that needs to be done
did I but I guess I haven't been here in
a while either so fine p.o box one one
four was a key oh wait what for yoo-hoo
why is it oh I found a but I think about
a bug okay four four one got a saute
knife even though you're holding it
you're still pretty sure there's no such
thing as a saute knife anyway it's too
thin to use as a weapon so it's not even
worth stealing
mm-hmm back to the chef also four for
one well I know how to saute knives all
right one one for ah for treasons
ballistic charts
that's the one that blew up the house
mmm interesting and I need some help
tracking down some missing mail what do
you mean a mail delivery went missing on
bread Wed and I'm hunting it down on
behalf of our mayor the local mail
station has a bunch of route maps but I
don't know which one I need hmm that
information exactly secret but I
supposed to just give it out either but
deliver go missing is bad news oh I
suppose all right this is once your
sayings okay so each map code as a
number on it what the hell hey son gives
you a cheat sheet for reference find the
right map at the Postal Service weigh
station know what that means I'm gonna
read this this chart is full of details
on the precision firing of the deme
Culver and artillery cannon you know
what I bet that cannon could blow the
vault door open it exams and Rio Rancho
p'n if you could figure out a way to
target it oh good idea fire the cannon
of the poor unsuspecting house that was
already fired upon by the cannon oh hey
it's you
thanks for telling me about this place
instead of arresting me for shooting me
in the head and then arresting me no
problem I'm not really a bounty under
any way just looking out for help people
well you sure did help me out I'll
really appreciate the opportunity and
things are going pretty well not a thing
yeast monster yeah yeah what can I get
you I don't know what do you got muscle
mystic ality moxie if I could actually
eat anything else I would probably do
that but you know I think I'm okay yeah
cows blood yeah years of being stuck in
the nose of a cow have done nothing to
finish on this thing I don't know what
I'm supposed to do with that but I don't
I don't want to wear it I don't want to
wear it any um anywhere on my body I
think I'm pretty good okay I'm gonna
leave this be is anybody else here wait
it's no one else set up shop yet what
the hell is happening what I thought I
had more oh that's oh man how much have
I not done then okay anyway I gotta find
the next place for me to go which is
gonna be I just thought of it I was just
thinking about four trees in that over
there long way pretty much across the
entire world
where's jumble neck mine I want to go to
jumble neck mine oh it's on the way
barely ooh oh rocks probably some mind
leavings that got piled up here search
the rocks you pug around in the rocks
but don't forget you think of interest I
don't know what I was expecting
hello a sign it says jumble neck mine
what is this meaning this a name are
names for things really don't mean
anything no Gary is meaning orange
blossom not sure what to do with this
knowledge barrel is full of old grease
I'll take some I'll scoop a handful put
in my bag what disguise just said I
would sass me game what just grab a
handful no I mean what I said and I
wanted freak you except for the dust all
over everything in the fact that the
guide the desk is ghost this looks like
a regular mine for its office oh okay
standard-issue miner's helmet hanging on
it
I got a miner's helmet old calendar
stopped working work stop I thought this
said that gallon to stop working months
ago I'm an idiot this guy's is busy
shuffling the ghosts of papers on his
desk excuse me kid I'm busy here I've
got a mind run take a hike okay this
mine is still running I haven't seen
anyone around we're minors kid if you
saw anyone up here and after fire them
for not doing their job I'm not gonna do
that voice how's business oh just great
hunky freakin dory see their face this
is my happy face and I'm double excited
about answering questions from some
random kid that wandered into my office
while I'm working
look at how ecstatic I am it's quite a
silver tooth you've gotten that
sarcastic grin I made it myself and I
made a few little silver trinkets in my
time now go away the calendars out today
what that's like six months old I like
the picture okay scram do you know
you're a ghost do you know you're a pain
in the ass
no I'm serious you see me laughing okay
all right how's biz neo okay never mind
there's nothing here left for that is he
the safe is dirty but solid looking get
away from that the ghostly figure behind
the desk growls well take a closer look
you stooped down to take a closer look
at the safe that's pretty standard ever
duty
the doubt that combination lock hey
something wrong with your ears I told
you to get away from there try to open
this what why you did come here nope
running okay see ya dude rolling off
into the mine I guess very nothing
interesting over here why is there
nothing it's just icky over here why do
you have to tell me there's nothing
interesting all right
the elevator is pretty dusty inside and
doesn't appear to have maintained for
quite a while it does seem functional
but the control lever it said that weird
is chained and padlocked you also know
that the shaft is totally silent he did
expect to hear the rumbling of mine
carts and the clanking of pickaxes
echoing up from below but there's
nothing all right
he picked the lock removed the chains to
get the lever a Yank the elevator
shudders is it begins to descend
accompanied by the sound of clanking
chains and grinding pulleys very quickly
it becomes too dark for you to see you
pull out your landing very slowly the
elevator reaches its destination you
pull the door open and peer into the
gloom alrighty then that was a lot of
what-have-you for this full of rocks
nothing special
oh I get to do the cart things ah
environmental story till we would hold
pickaxe what does that even mean
as the initials H H carved into the
handle not much Hogarth Hughes from the
I run giant not much good for mining any
more but you could still knock someone's
head off with it good to know I guess
it's a headless skeletons skull its
skull old scholars okay looks like there
was a cave-in
check it out alright there isn't much to
see except for Ross it's quite a lot of
them though so if you want to look at
the rocks it's a great selection to
choose from alrighty then
it's like someone forgot their lunch box
down here there must have been real
hungry by now I got a paper bag whoa I
don't know what to do with that I got a
paper bag though so that's nice
hello pull the lever lever is told ah I
know what that is it's great is old
dynamite dynamite gets very dangerous
when it ages but you know better than to
try and stop you from taking a stick if
you've decided you want one I have
decided officially that I will do that
thing that you don't want me to do here
I go I have decided that I have a nun I
don't recommend you do a lot of hopping
up and down while you're carrying it
unstable stick of dynamite the
nitroglycerin is sweaty this dynamite
was crystallized on the outside this
makes it extremely dangerous and you
should probably not try to use it in a
fight I mean you also shouldn't be
carrying around to your pockets too late
for warning Oh what'll happen if I hop
up and down what's the worst could
happen oh I wonder what could happen as
I seem to be checking off this Lantern
wide oh the cart is full of rocks it
doesn't seem to be anything particularly
special about them ah stick that old
dynamite in there you wedge in a stick
it wasn't stable dynamite into the cart
this can't possibly go awry oh I know
exactly how possibly it could go alright
so I got to shove it after a moment
you're distant Clank so what am I do I
think that other thing was like a
spring-loaded launcher result suppose
stick of antique dynamite in there first
why how about I pull this lever up bang
oh it seems like it's gonna require
something heavier duty than a can of oil
how about a cooking some grease with my
hand or put it in that paper bag I just
found all the trees can hold it a paper
bag right baby
take some yep I put it in the paper bag
hopefully this will come in handy if you
have a good reason to be carrying around
a paper sandwich bag full of old grease
I was like that's oh I didn't even press
use on that it just assumed I wanted to
go into the mine sure thing alright
anyway I'm gonna grease this bad boy up
oh that's boink grease up that lever you
dump a bunch of grease into the
mechanism and use the sandwich bag as a
sort of the term goo [ __ ] up there in a
while I don't know if I've ever sort of
goo [ __ ] up there without getting too
much of it on your hands pull that lever
you yank hard on the lever and it
releases the mechanisms wound up springs
launching the minecart down the track
with a terrific Wang noise off in the
distance you hear a kaboom Oh about that
what oh look it's open now a man I
really could have goofed that if I'd had
to go in the other way and then I would
have been
give the wreck minecart a salute in
respect for its valor and service all
right it's hard to tell at a glance but
on closer inspection this guy seems to
have died in face down a basement or
prayer pose praying to the pit maybe
it's difficult to say
let me just been napping weird the
skeleton seems to be reaching out with
that weird statuette reaching out with
the statute with the hands having fallen
off it's impossible to tell all right
some kind of weird statuette okay I got
a weird statuette it is tarnished and
blackened silver statue and in the shape
of some sort of creature you can't
exactly tell what it is specifically or
even if it has two legs or four legs or
wings or what but it's depicted with
reverence looking at it makes your
stomach feel weird like you're starving
but also full of the point of nausea at
the same time this goes in your offhand
no if I want that in fact I don't want
that I don't want that at all it's made
of silver and tarnished Gartner's you
know whatever oh it seems pretty deep
you've kicked a rock into it but never
here the bottom throw something into it
you look through you're packing
something that might be good to throw
into the bottomless pit you hold up the
silver to skull alas poor a never mind
I'll throw it in the hole why not I
don't want it chuck it ro toss is going
to the pit as it falls it yells I'm
coming oh that's a little dude I don't
even know what an idea wait take the
idol out of your bag you don't like the
way it looks in this dim light you don't
like the way it looks at you in this dim
light
roll it in throw the idol into the page
the weird feeling in your stomach fades
away although you get a sense of well
it's like if you heard someone chuck and
you except you didn't hear anything and
there isn't anyone behind you ah so is
there someone chuckling behind me or not
all right
ah the cursed blood goblet good grief
why are you even carrying this thing
around I don't know I'll chuck it in the
hole pinch the gross thing in the hall
good riddance
hey it's free XP Oh introductory next
Maxis Boop could be your first step
serves real power but at what cost throw
it in the hole oh good good I can get
rid of all my [ __ ] the [ __ ] that I
really shouldn't be carrying ah the
comeback cover blurb says it can teach
you how to steal people's blood that's
Odin oh that sounds horrible you toss a
bug into the hole alright okay I think
I've tossed all my Garbo in there that's
it's good hey if you don't go down that
route you can get a goody goody
two-shoes hole to throw in that
wonderful eye maybe I don't know anyway
I don't know if there's any way to get
to this oh he's gone since no one is
here you're free to rummage around in
this desk let's do it oh I found some
extra Crystal Turkey great just what I
wanted
alright you stooped down I'm gonna crack
this safe a sack of meat mmm this thin
and a weird knife this knife has a thin
twisty stiletto blade made of tarnish
black silver it looks wicked sharp but
holding it makes you feel a little
uncomfortable like someone's whispering
your name but you can't quite hear them
also no one's whispering your name and
they're not standing behind you and
there's no one there and you didn't hear
anything
score I guess the office safe is empty
you're the one who emptied it remember
no no not at all I don't remember that
at all I don't know what you're talking
about
I need another shooting nanny eventually
but I'll give that
later I don't use deploy snake enough Oh
summons a snake tweet what good is a
briefcase full of eggs if you can't
occasionally pull a snake out and tell
it what to do
fricking love that also did I do I have
any like books keep forgetting if I
actually have any book what is this one
flip through the book most of it
uneventful
okay all right all right now I'm on the
way there's been a fun detour but I got
a go-to for treason because I got a
Frick okay sure
Oh a lightning snake ah now a dead snake
okay thank you very much for that okay
back to for treason because I got a I
got a blow up a cellar in a poor
beleaguered farm that's already been
blown up
Debbie Culver and cannon look closely
it's a fine candidate Oh ball that I
have forever you look through the range
fire on the cannon yeah but you can't
see any indication of anything you want
to shoot at and you decide not to waste
the ball I know real bad I want to shoot
at ah oh I want wait why not did I find
it yet oh wait unable let's buy wait a
faint way this makes a Woo's noises and
gestures to its roadside grave marker
which has fallen over for some reason
it's a huge millstone Oh muscle that
back up Judd Nelson at 1837 died when a
millstone fell over on him oh my gosh
those weren't sticks they were oh no
yeah those are definite sticks okay
never mind then was it oh maybe I never
went near or inspected it I know I want
to blow up the cellar Oh
books are wrecked but this cellars here
place a targeting flare oh it's a
cannonball investigate
the horror okay are now back to fart
trees oh alright fine anyway bang okay
is dead alright
they were gone now when four trees in
here we go so if I blast this blast II
blue light it up gnome if that didn't
open the vault door then these grapes
are probably sour anyway is it a wine
cellar is that what you mean by grapes I
don't understand that but okay alright
I'll go convenient ladder on that
alright books and books and books that's
exactly what I needed I need oh this
book is full of tips and tricks about
the ancient art of fixing machines by
hitting them really hard also people in
the face oh you quickly memorize the
entire book you got a book Burke
percussive maintenance Tom to get
smacking you know market buyers favorite
motto time to get smoking that's what
I'd like to say when you're done reading
it you notice that the book spine is
cracked
really hard but you end up just smashing
the books to powder oops
Oh Frick time to get smacking ladies and
gentlemen oh that's what I was looking
for you got modern snake oiler good I
needed that not the map me dumb EMU oh I
need a good medicine fan hammer
I need dad I want him to create up at
high noon noon time to get smacking on
the fan hammer
I got fan Amer oh I do need that Oh
that'd be nice
that's real nice you unload round after
round into a nearby cactus just to see
how it feels it feels pretty good it's
time to get smack and no cactus gonna
stand in my way unfortunately a stray
spark from under your shot sets the
magazine on fire and you're unable to
prevent it from being destroyed
ah you choose the book with the most
sensational sounding tile how to cheat
at poker cheating as part of the game of
poker but getting caught doing it is
still this advantageous this book
purports to turn your cheating into
sneaky cheat it gives you the dirty
poker skill oh it does it now Oh does it
indeed you quickly memorize the entire
book so as to can you learn how to cheat
at a weird variant of Poker they play in
these parts so as to conceal the
evidence of your dirty dealings you eat
the book
let's smack up the tables let's get to
smacking everybody else there his lock
case contains a book labeled gold metal
silver smithing ok alright
you make sure artwork and grab the book
this book written by expert Joel or
Dabney bones detailed advanced
techniques and melting silver things and
turning them into other silver things
grace was way I'm gonna do this you read
the book and learn a lot more about
silver smithing than you knew before
alright excellent after you're finished
reading it you absent-mindedly drop it
into a nearby mailbox and are unable to
retrieve it happy birthday mr. postman
congratulations I guess
alright rich vein poor vein this copy of
a popular financial advice book from a
few years ago it's rare now because
various Crusades took destroy every copy
of it you quickly memorize the entire
book vainglorious you know how to get a
lot more meat out of meat veins well
it's too bad over he picked up all the
meat veins in the area unfortunately the
book was sold and crumbly that reading
it once caused it to be destroyed so
much for literary preservation tragic
the greatest love poem ever written the
dust jacket of this book is missing so I
can't tell you who who wrote it
[Music]
make any sense read it poem is so good
you're afraid to even read it because
you might fall in love with the book
okay sure yeah all right whatever
whatever sure yeah okay anyway god that
was amazing oh man
I just it's so nice every single thing
that you see in this game every single
thing is just dripping with so much
funny I love it all right so anyway
that's all the time I got for this
episode I've got a lot more stuff to do
I need to finish I keep forgetting that
in my double playthrough there are some
things in here that I haven't done
before but I do have percussive
maintenance now and my Hornswoggle n' is
up I just need to find something yard
and worthy so that the lady can knit it
and maybe like maybe she'll make
something for the little kid that wants
a toy I don't know either way thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think down the comments
below and as always I will see you
[Music]